[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's been
dune doing your mom and this video we're
breaking down everything you need to
know about paul atreides paul has quite
a complicated backstory another
character is pretty much portrayed early
on as being a savior his legacy is
actually far more complicated than that
and he's not the messiah figure that
everyone thinks he is in this video
we're going to be going over it all but
we need to drop a spoiler warning first
as this will be covering the character's
entire biography if you enjoy the video
then please hit the thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this each and every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into polar tradies
okay so in order to talk about paul we
firstly have to talk about the benny
jesuit they're a very complicated group
and the religion is pretty much as alpha
power as much as the rest of the
characters in dune are june is very much
about the idea that following messianic
figures can actually be somewhat foolish
and the benny have used the idea of
prophecy coupled with superstition in
order for lots of people to follow them
without question in the book it's
explicitly stated that they use the
religion in order to control the masses
however the tv and film adaptations tend
to gloss over this and instead paint
paul out as basically being the chosen
one this is pretty much a lie though and
as we learn he was very much
manufactured through science experiments
carried out by the religious order now
throughout the saga we very much
question whether paul is actually the
quiz at tatarach or if he simply fit
that role and thus everyone kind of
followed behind him it was said that the
quiz at haddorach would have incredible
abilities but as we see throughout the
saga this is very much brought on by
paul's upbringing and the copious
amounts of spice that he'd been
subjected to it was a quiz that's had a
rash give a dog a bone everyone spoiling
no way home now as we discover more
about the benny jesuit we learned that
for centuries they'd secretly performed
selective breeding processes which
basically narrowed down the bloodlines
so that they could prop someone up as a
new leader of the people in order to
control the masses the jesuit believed
that the daughter of the etreides should
marry the son of household conan and
that this would very much bring the two
sides together and usher forth the
supreme bloodline that would be seen as
the chosen ones however jessica went
against this and she chose to have a son
instead because that's what duke later
wanted thus paul was born and he spent
his early years on kaladan which is the
ancestral home of the atreides the benny
gesserat were furious over this but they
didn't want to completely scrap the
breeding processes that they'd gone
through for centuries
and thus allowed things to continue
whilst they kept a close eye on paul
paul was trained by his mother in the
ways of the benny jesuit and his father
also selected the best teachers from his
ranks in order to instill knowledge
within him now originally it was helped
by leto that paul would become a mentat
which are basically the human versions
of a computer in june you might notice
that the high ranking officials don't
really have any pcs or apple macs with
them but what they do have is people who
have black markings on their lower lips
these are very much extremely
knowledgeable people that are used as
living computers in order to advise and
help the house leaders however it was
hoped that paul would go beyond this and
that he'd basically be a leader with
these capabilities which would make him
a formidable threat now on the other
side of this the benny jesuit wanted to
see if paul could indeed be the quiz at
hararaj and thus they tested him with
the gumdy bar paul was subjected to more
pain than anyone ever had prior to it
and he passed which made the benny start
to believe that he could indeed be
fulfilling their prophecy paul had
premonitions of the future and these
prophetic powers would come to be very
important to how events would play out
now during these years the emperor had
grown fearful that the atreides were
gaining power and he worried that they
could one day overthrow him and his
family thus he withdrew the harkonnens
from the planet arrakis and instead
tasked the atreides with mining spice
from it paul's father wanted somewhat of
an alliance with the natives of the
planet and this would massively go on to
influence the character as he grew older
now upon arriving on the planet it
wasn't too long before he encountered
spice and this massively altered his
perception and it opened his mind to the
world around him it was predicted that
the quizets had a rash would be able to
see all time at once and this somewhat
opened his ability to foresee things now
another thing that the tv shows and
films don't really get across is that
the book very much feels like an
ensemble piece in its early chapters
however over the years as people have
tried to streamline the story so that it
could be adapted for the screen a lot of
this has been dropped by the wayside so
that the soul focus can mainly be on
paul if i had to draw comparisons i'd
basically say it's what would happen if
he tried to adapt game of thrones into a
two and a half hour movie he'd probably
just put jon snow as the main character
even though there's so many other people
around him who have important parts as
well paul does experience a lot of the
major events firsthand though so i can
see why he's very much always getting
put forward as the main main protagonist
now after an assassination attempt on
him failed the benny gesserat leader
mother guys helen heim went to baron
harkonnen and said that in the upcoming
planned ambush that paul and his mother
should be spared the baron agreed to
this and along with the emperor's forces
known as the sadhuka they launched an
attack on arrakis the baron had captured
the wife of dr ua and he blackmailed him
into lowering the shields on the planet
and also betraying the duke ua did this
but he gave the duke a fake tooth that
would release poisonous gas when bitten
into it with this the duke managed to
kill a vast number of the baron's forces
but the baron himself was able to escape
because of his shield and levitation
technology now whilst this was going on
paul and his mother were captured by the
barons forces and they were flown out
into the desert to be abandoned to the
elements this would still keep the
baron's word but it would very much
banish them to a fate that would kill
them pretty quickly however paul and his
mother were able to escape and overpower
the barons forces and they flew out into
the desert before crash landing now it's
during this time that paul encountered
more spice and he started to become
aware of his origins and what he was
bred for it's also during this time that
he had visions of living amongst the
fremen and it pretty much put him on a
path to joining their forces now
depending on what you watch or read
depends on what happens next but it is
important to bear in mind that duncan
idaho and dr liek kinds are killed
whilst gurney ends up wandering out into
the desert and joining another tribe
paul also learns that his mother is
pregnant and the child becomes very
important as we get further into the
story paul and jessica come across the
fremen and after fighting to the death
with a member called james he and his
mother are accepted into the group in
the source material the freeman gained a
lot of respect for football because he
cries after killing james because
moisture and water is so sought after in
the desert they realize how much james's
death means to him and it's not too long
before they start to follow him now it's
at this point that he meets the woman of
his dreams channy but bull's love life
is very complicated in the book if the
fremen kill another member of the tribe
then they have to look after that
person's family and he has to take
responsibility for james's wife and kids
add to this the wifey ends up getting
later on and it all just gets very very
complicated now channy in the books is
actually the daughter of liek kines and
we also discover that baron hart conan
is jessica's father making paul his
grandson he and his mother start to
teach the fram in a fighting technique
known as the weirding way which allows
them to use sound as a weapon they also
discovered that lia kinds had found a
way to create reservoirs underground and
we witnessed the freman's great supply
of water paul ends up adopting the name
muadeeb which is a desert mouse and
jessica undergoes a ritual to become a
reverend mother this involves drinking
the water of life which vastly opens up
someone's conscious and because she's
pregnant her baby ends up getting these
powers too the child named alia is
pre-born and she ages extremely fast and
carries a high level of intelligence in
the desert paul starts to slowly build
the framing up as a formidable force and
word of this reaches the emperor and
baron har conan his nephew rabanne had
been put in charge of spice mining on
arrakis but the fremen constantly
destroy the operations and this leads to
the house having a lot of issues paul
and the fremon realized that if one has
the power to destroy the spice then they
are the ones who control it and they
carry out several raids now during these
paul comes across gurney which is
hilarious in the 1984 version as he just
kind of stumbles across patrick stewart
who has a bald mullet i haven't seen
each other for ages and they're just
like well bro long time no see fancy
seen you here now gurney is still torn
up about the betrayal and he actually
believes jessica had to be the one who
was behind it gurney attacks her but
he's stopped by paul who then worries
that because he didn't foresee it that
his abilities aren't strong enough paul
2 drinks the water of life and because
it's only meant for women he's knocked
out for about a month however when he
awakens he's able to see across all time
in space and he truly becomes the quiz
at haddarach sensing that the emperor
and baron are coming to arrakis to crush
the fremen rebels paul starts to train
his army even harder and he learns how
to ride on the back of sandwich the
barons forces launch an attack and they
capture alia and take her to both the
emperor and the harkonnens paul in the
fremen then storm the capital and during
this ambush alia kills the baron paul
comes face to face with the emperor and
he fights the baron's nephew fade who's
played by sting in the 1984 film someone
called the police because he's doing a
lot of blue steel to an illegal extent
throughout the whole movie now paul
kills him and he forces the emperor to
abdicate the throne he says that if he
doesn't he'll destroy all the spies on
the planet and as it's tied into so much
of their society the emperor doesn't
really have a choice however the emperor
makes him promise that he'll marry his
daughter princess ireland and this kind
of adds to the complicated love triangle
between paul chaney and her now from
this point on paul becomes the emperor
and he makes arrakis the capital of the
universe that's pretty much the end of
the first book and we go into tune
messiah for the next part of his story
now this was combined with the following
buck children of june in order to make
the sci-fi mini series of the same name
we will be using clips from that but all
the characters look vastly different so
yeah try keep up your schmuck now also
like the video now messiah takes place
roughly 12 years after june and we
learned that paul's forces have all gone
on crusades throughout the galaxy
carrying out a g-hat they've
exterminated 61 billion people and ball
is pretty much powerless to control the
religious extremists that are destroying
the universe he's now going fully under
the name muhadeeb and there's lots of
unintentionally funny moments in
children of june where people just cry
out in anger mua
[Music]
now that this is what i was talking
about with paul not really being all
that heroic and though he's not carrying
out the bad acts himself many people do
so in his name because of this the benny
jesuit spacing guild and princess
ireland all planted a throne paul and
they bring in a clone of duncan idaho
which is known as a goaler upon hearing
a trigger word being said this will
activate and kill paul but the back
stabbing doesn't stop there there are
also rebel groups within the fremen who
despise what he's done to arrakis as he
slowly started to terraform the planet
and bring water and rivers to it they
see this as destroying their way of life
and they all conspire to kill him before
it's too late now whilst all this is
going on the princess attempts to have a
child with paul but he refuses to touch
it he doesn't want to have one with
cheney either as he foresees that it
will bring about her death paul is
almost killed when an enemy sets off a
bomb known as a stone burner which
completely blinds him upon looking at it
however because of his clairvoyance he's
still able to see and he has a lot of
visions about his future children and
those who wish to wrong him he also
starts to see things through chenny's
eyes and this helps them get around now
paul ends up getting jenny pregnant and
she gives birth to two twins that are
pre-born like alia we learn that the
princess has been slowly poisoning
channy and this finally takes its toll
on her as she gives birth ball utters
the words she's gone which triggers
duncan into activating but upon
remembering his entire life he decides
to go against his programming and he
helps paul instead an assassin attempts
to kill him but using the sight of his
children he's able to murder them
instead now according to fremont
tradition if someone is blind then they
must wander into the desert in order to
no longer be a burden to the people this
is because the fremen would simply be
wasting water keeping them alive and
they see the person as being a drag on
society which is isn't is a nice message
i suppose is it though anyway due to his
legacy being secured with his children
paul goes into the desert whilst alya
becomes the new ruler of the empire now
this takes us into children of june in
which we follow paul's kids letter ii
and kanema after another big time jump
we join them as teenagers and we learn
that duncan has now married alia alia is
pretty much continuing paul's somewhat
tyrannical reign and due to being
pre-born she has strong psychic
abilities this enables her to possess
all the memories of her ancestors which
actually manifests the ghost of the
baron who constantly haunts her she's
pretty messed up due to constantly being
bombarded with things from the past and
it massively affects her personality now
the capital is constantly visited by a
mysterious preacher who talks about how
bad the muhaddib rule was and how it
damned them all normally alia would kill
this man however there are rumors that
it might be paul and dun dun dun turns
out it's actually him now lady jessica
returns to the planet and she too sees
the preacher and starts to realize how
dangerous that aliyah is whilst all this
is going on ledo and genema escape into
the desert after an assassination
attempt is made on them as we watch the
fallout in the capital leno the second
ends up bonding with baby sandwich and
this gives him superhuman speed and
invulnerability he pretty much becomes
the next stage of evolution and that's
not an x-men pun because james mcavoy is
playing him now out in the desert he
encounters his father which is where the
truth is revealed later very much
becomes another messiah figure and the
pair have visions that he can lead
humanity on a golden path of
transcendence paul warns against this as
he saw the same thing but later believes
that doing this is the only way to avoid
the extinction of humanity now it's
during this time that jessica arranges a
marriage for ganema this is to a
character called faraday who i'll be
here talking about all day and i kind of
just want to remain on paul for the
meantime now it's a grand event and all
of the framing including stilgar's
forces swarmed the capital on the back
of giant sand worms in order to bring an
end to alya's reign paul arrives and
gives a final speech that shuts down the
religion that worships him and it also
denounces his sister during this paul is
stabbed in the back by a local friend
and man and he dies at the scene in
lado's arms his last words are it's in
your hands now son and he passes away
ali returns to her throne and later
arrives with his sister lado ends up
denouncing her and he states that he's
there to seize the throne he defeats her
forces and takes her on easily besting
her in the process this sends her brain
into overdrive and she's possessed by
the baron for a moment which takes a
heavy toll on her psyche she begs for
help and later then gives her a knife
and says help yourself it's really dark
and though she initially goes to stab
lato she ends up turning the blade on
herself alia's last words are i want my
brother and she passes away in her
mother's arms later goes to stilga and
gives him not only alia's water but also
the ring that was passed down through
the atreides family he says that it's a
symbol of the muadibe which will remind
them that all humans make mistakes and
that all leaders are humans it very much
shuts down the idea of the messiah and
the dangers that can come from following
a figure like this especially because
humans aren't all-knowing lado
disappears into the desert running at
supersonic speed and genema prophesizes
that he will return to her and ask that
she helps him to die from this point
onwards gennima takes the throne and
though she doesn't marry farradin she
says that one day they may fall in love
much in the same way that lady jessica
was never leto's wife she doesn't think
that they should wed either and that's
basically the life and death of paul the
tradies the muadeeb the preacher the
christ-like figure of the tune story i
really hope you enjoyed the video and i
try to keep things as simple as possible
but let us know below what your favorite
aspects of the character are if you want
something else to watch we've got a lot
of tune related videos on screen now
that i hope you definitely go and head
over to i'm really looking forward to
part two as well and i might be doing
some more videos down the line so make
sure you subscribe if you want to see
more of them without the way thank you
for sitting through the video i've been
poor i'll see you on the next one take
care peace